talking of back to school the valley
came together to help the sponsor of
this next segment silver state schools
credit union to give back to classrooms
here's more on their efforts to support
the community and how you can join in
[Music]
hi i'm scott arkiels president and ceo
of silver state schools credit union and
we're here at our cimarron branch which
is on west flamingo and we wanted to
talk today about our school supply drive
that we just finished
we're absolutely so thankful to our
members and the community for the
monetary and school supply donations and
with their help our people over profit
foundation donated over 100 backpacks
and school supply to rex bell elementary
in addition to the backpack donation we
were also able to make school supply
donations to both stanford elementary
and the girls athletic leadership school
which is known as gals
the families and students who are
benefiting from your donations along
with the school staff are incredibly
thankful for everyone's generous giving
silver state schools credit union was
also proud to partner with the las vegas
lights football club for this year's
back to school supply drive so i'm often
asked how we were able to pull off such
a
great school supply drive and i may be
biased but i personally think silver
state schools credit union has some of
the greatest employees in the las vegas
valley we would not be able to volunteer
at our local schools or host our
community events like our back to school
supply drive without such incredible and
dedicated team members anyone who may be
interested in coming aboard with us can
actually visit us online at
silverstatecu.com
careers for more information you can
also visit us online to get the most
updated information about our credit
union if you follow us and like us on
social media our social medias are kept
up to date with all the exciting things
happening at silver state schools credit
union including our community events our
social media sites are also a great
resource for our members for things like
holiday hours and special promotions
that we have i'm often asked if you have
to be a teacher to become a member and
the answer is not at all in fact almost
anyone can become a member school
educators administrators and staff are
all eligible for membership but if
you're a school volunteer a student a
retiree or a parent or guardian of a
student involved in an educational
organization in nevada you can also
become a member at silver state schools
credit union you can also join the
credit union by making a one-time
donation to vegas pbs you can apply for
membership by stopping in at any one of
our 10 branch locations where a member
service representative would be more
than happy to assist you or you can
visit us and apply online at
silverstatecu.com
thank you to silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring this segment for
more just call 702-733-8820